meagan Marco and Prince Harry are
handling the coronavirus like everyone
else let's all just rally together as
Buckingham Palace continues to make
changes to the Royal schedule the Sussex
azar following suit and are proceeding
with caution a source tells ET that
Megan and Harry are taking appropriate
measures and they're following
government advice we're assuming that
means the Canadian government which of
course is Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
and if you're following the news you
know that his wife Sophie tested
positive for Kovan 19 last week now
here's how that news hits even closer to
home for Megan and Harry during their
final royal engagements in the UK
earlier this month
Harry hugged Formula One driver Lewis
Hamilton during their joint event the
Silverstone experience and here's the
thing days before that hug Hamilton was
at an event with Sophie Trudeau and
Idris Elba who are both good friends of
Megan and Harry and like Sophie Idris
has it too this morning I got some test
results back for coronavirus and it came
back positive now we're in no way saying
that Harry was exposed
Hamilton hasn't said anything about
being sick in fact on Monday he tweeted
about staying safe
amid coronavirus concerns but the
friendships are worth noting according
to our source Megan and Harry will act
accordingly if and when they are
specifically made aware of being in
contact with someone who's tested
positive we watched the duo take extra
precautions during their final royal
appearance at the Commonwealth Day
Service last Monday one of the things
that was so notable it was the absence
of any handshaking and of course this is
because of the the spread of the corona
virus here's Prince Harry exchanging an
elbow bump with performer Craig David
and Megan Markel simply flashed a smile
to each attendee before chatting away
the Duke and Duchess are currently back
in Canada with their son Archie
meanwhile the royal family much like the
entertainment industry is taking new
measures to isolate from large crowds
during the pandemic
the queen has cancelled all her upcoming
palace garden parties as well as a royal
visit she was scheduled to make later
this month
[Music]